you may qualify to get Eargo at
no cost to you.
>> Bill: YOU -- BAN ON
EVICTIONS.
AFTER THE WHITE HOUSE SAID IT’S
HANDS WERE TIED BY A RECENT
SUPREME COURT RULING AT THE END
OF JUNE.
THEY LOST THAT RULING.
HERE WE ARE IN AUGUST AND
THEY’RE GOING BACK TO IT
REGARDLESS.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY
LOUISIANA MEMBER OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
GOOD DAY TO YOU.
A FEW QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
YOUR COLLEAGUE TOM COTTON
TWEETED BIDEN ADMITS IT’S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND HE
CONCLUDES WITH THE WORD LAWLESS.
WHAT’S GOING ON IN THAT TOWN?
>> I THINK IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THAT HAS NEVER STOPPED THE
PERMANENT WASHINGTON TYPES FROM
DOING SOMETHING.
I DO THINK IT’S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND I THINK
IT’S UNWISE.
I DON’T WANT ANYBODY TO HAVE TO
LOSE THEIR HOME BUT LOOK, IT IS
TIME THAT WE REJOIN THE WORLD.
AND WE HAVE SPENT -- WE MEANING
THE CONGRESS -- ABOUT $4.7
TRILLION HELPING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE RECOVER FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS.
OUR ECONOMY IS CLEARLY
RECOVERING AND IN MY STATE WE
SENT LOUISIANA $550 MILLION TO
HELP PEOPLE WITH RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND ONLY SPENT 50.
THAT TELLS ME THERE IS NOT A
BIG NEED THERE.
>> Bill: OKAY.
AMONG YOUR COLLEAGUES THEN WHAT
DO THEY TELL YOU ABOUT THE
NATURAL FORCES OF CAPITALISM?
YOU CAN LOOK TO SOME OF THESE
STATES RIGHT NOW IN NEBRASKA
UNEMPLOYMENT IS 2 1/2%.
THAT’S AWESOME.
AND UTAH 2.7%.
NEW HAMPSHIRE AND SOUTH DAKOTA
IT’S 2.9%.
IDAHO 3%.
YOUR POINT ABOUT THE ECONOMY
RECOVERING IS WELL TAKEN.
AT WHAT POINT DO WE TAKE OUR
FOOT OFF THE GAS?
>> WE’RE THERE.
WE HAVE HAD A V-SHAPED RECOVERY.
WE HAVE -- WE’RE NOW GENERATING
A GDP THAT IS SLIGHTLY GREATER
THAN IT WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED.
WE HAVE WHAT, 10 MILLION JOBS
THAT WE CAN’T FILL, WE SET A
RECORD LAST QUARTER, WE WILL
PROBABLY SET A RECORD THIS
QUARTER.
OUR ECONOMY IS BACK.
AND IT IS TIME THAT -- NOW, WE
STILL HAVE THE VIRUS WITH US,
WHICH WE CAN TALK ABOUT, BUT IT
IS TIME TO REJOIN OUR LIVES AND
WE CAN’T GIVE FREE RENT TO
EVERYBODY.
IF YOU WANT FREE RENT, THERE IS
NOTHING FREE, BILL.
EVERYTHING FREE SOMEBODY HAD TO
WORK FOR.
>> Bill: THIS IS LIKE FREE RENT
TO INFINITY.
I PULLED THOSE UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS FOR THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL." THE HEADLINE.
EVICTION BAN HAS TO END
SOMETIME.
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS HAVE TO
WORK IT OUT AND BETTER NOW THAN
LATER.
SUPREME COURT SAID YOU CAN’T DO
THIS AFTER JULY.
IT IS AUGUST NOW.
SHOULD THE SUPREME COURT HAVE
AN EMERGENCY RULING AND COME
BACK AND SAY THAT’S AGAINST THE
LAW?
>> YES.
AND I SUSPECT SOMEBODY WILL
FILE SUIT AND TRY TO GET IN
FRONT OF THE SUPREME COURT.
NOW WHETHER THE SUPREME COURT
WILL TAKE THE CASE OR NOT I
DON’T KNOW.
BUT LET ME SAY IT AGAIN WITH
PERMANENT WASHINGTON TYPES WHO
RUN THIS PLACE AND UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION MAKE MOST OF THE
DECISIONS, THE CONSTITUTION IS
JUST A NUISANCE.
>> Bill: YOU MENTION COVID.
HERE IS YOUR STATE WHERE IT
RANKS, IN THE BOTTOM FIVE OF
VACCINATION, LOUISIANA CHECKS
IN AT 37.1%.
BEHIND YOU ALABAMA,
MISSISSIPPI, ARKANSAS AND
WYOMING.
WHAT IS HAPPENING AND WHY YOU
THINK PEOPLE ARE HESITANT?
>> THIS IS AMERICA.
WE’RE ALL ENTITLED TO OUR
OPINION.
HERE IS MINE.
NUMBER ONE, THE VACCINE WORKS,
THE NRNA MESSENGER TECHNOLOGY
WORKS.
IT IS THE SINGLE GREATEST
ACHIEVEMENT OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
I HAVE -- I BELIEVE IN IT AND
HAVE TAKEN TWO SHOTS.
IF THEY CAME TO ME AND SAID IN
ORDER TO GET A BOOSTER YOU’VE
GOT TO TAKE A SHOT IN THE
EYEBALL, I WOULD DO IT.
WHY?
BECAUSE I DON’T WANT TO DIE.
THIS STUFF IS LIKE PLAYING
RUSSIAN ROULETTE.
IT CAN KILL YOU.
NUMBER TWO, IF YOU WANT TO WEAR
A MASK IN MY OPINION YOU
SHOULD, IF YOU DON’T YOU
SHOULDN’T.
THE MASK ISSUE IS NOT NEARLY AS
IMPORTANT AS TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE SERIOUSLY THINK ABOUT
TAKING THE VACCINE.
NUMBER THREE, WE’RE IN A FOURTH
WAVE.
THE SINGLE BIGGEST THING THAT
HAS UNDERMINED OUR EFFORTS TO
MAKE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WE’RE IN THE FOURTH
WAVE IS PRESIDENT OBAMA’S
DECISION TO HOLD A BIRTHDAY
BASH WITH 400 PEOPLE.
NOW, I’VE NEVER SEEN SOMETHING
SO IRRESPONSIBLE.
HE KNOWS BETTER.
HE NEEDS TO CANCEL IT AND HAVE
A BEER AND A PERSONAL PAN PIZZA
AT HOME WITH HIS WIFE.
>> Bill: HE HAS DONE JUST THAT.
ONLY FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
SCALED IT BACK FOR THIS WEEKEND.
>> HE NEEDS TO CANCEL IT.